[Music]
in overrated news
that's not overrated submitted by insert
trap music save your time money and
sanity by skipping some of these
overrated attractions in the USA Oh
Michael reading in Hollywood I'll tell
you guys the detail for tourism tell me
the list and I'll tell you if it's worth
it or not
yeah so Business Insider they created
this uh anti tourism list
snaps thing oh it's all across the state
so it's like the number-one tourist trap
according to them in each space so we
can list through them if you guys want
to ask and you stay we can explore with
the tourist trap let's call it
California yeah so Nell man so for the
state of California it's the Hollywood
Walk of Fame
yep definitely I've never even done it
every time you go there there's always
going to be someone that's like you like
hip hop and then they put the headphones
on your ear you want to buy my CD I'm
gonna be famous parents all cities
anymore what do they do now mm maybe
that whole industry down us USB was one
of those little things SoundCloud links
oh yeah but I know where they give out
there's no more serious offense maybe
they still do I haven't but our cars
don't come with it our laptops don't
like that it has your car has a CD slot
yeah yours it 2016
oh oh yeah mine does too but it's hidden
yeah it's like a tiny slit that you
don't even really know exists but it's
their TV and DVD and I didn't know this
number one cars have like their six DVD
changer like you could say thanks to the
human and land in the drunk dozers I can
actually watch movies on my car I didn't
even notice you know the display thing
yes my range over mij oh yeah I didn't
know that you're a Range Rover
manager I know yet a jet engine operator
works I never watched it
hi fancy do you watch it uh no I just
realized that I had one until she yeah
it's my house it is there it is there
a DVD player oh wow but would I
recommend people to go see I'm always
lying don't let me hold you back from
living life homie you got to do it and
experience it for yourself what I
personally go let me give you the
reality of what the Hollywood Walk of
Fame is it's a bunch of people in like
Superman outfits and Wolverine and you
can do that at comic-con and whatever
you don't have to paint it like nah I'll
call it one there's a lot of people love
kiss everyone there's a lot of peepee
and I mean what are you looking at
you're just looking at stars with names
engraved yeah I know that I think the
cooler thing of that is the men's
janitor one you know where you can
actually like put your handprints and
like celebrities hands oh that's a dope
I like that one I think that like I was
watching the bunch of Jimmy Fallon stuff
one was getting my nails done yesterday
and chips being is based on subsets so I
think it's also one of those things
where for them if they're hoping to like
be picked up by like a Jimmy Fallon
thing or just like others one of the
chosen
maybe that's why they would go because I
was like man that kind of makes me want
to hang out there but it's like a
one-in-a-million chance I love Jimmy
Fallon so that was my only reason but
I'd rather just take him to like Rodeo
Drive because that's like the classic
thing you look at things you can't buy
and then you leave and then you cry la
experience yeah what others baked you
guys want to know the torch Negus yeah
no bad bad it is where's my the Venetian
gondolas
oh yeah I had know something yeah I
always wanted to do I want to do it too
when my girlfriend's was proposed to on
on the run dad oh you know what I did it
I know but that's good Oh like why don't
you just go to the real when I proposed
I proposed at the Eiffel Tower in Vegas
yeah money oh they have money or do
something that's like original I'd
rather go to Vegas and propose a like
old town or like it's an accountant and
uh do some other kind of actually or in
the desert while like dune buggy yeah
like something that's unique to that
place well I guess the Venetian gondola
its instead of actual Italy gonna I mean
that's like the next best thing
that's like ditching a boat while
someone paddles for me even gondolas in
Italy was all right that was awesome I
like this I did the water taxi so too
cheap to pay for the gondola he decided
it was time I had this guy who's like
pushing a boat but he's not [ __ ]
phones on his calm the whole time while
smoking a cigarette I was [ __ ]
yelling Italian tongs homie oh my god oh
yeah I would be pissed you're like no
but that's a true Italian experience and
got a leather jacket with the scarf he's
[ __ ] yelling at each other back yep
Bart loved it
chilly I hate it it's great [ __ ] work
something romantic crash all because
you're expecting a guy wearing a red
bandanna with blue stripes and [ __ ]
singing Dada I didn't want that I'm
learning rationally I knew it's going to
be some European Mafia looking guy and I
got exactly I'm like I got a photo a
really dope gondola dude there though I
mean he didn't give us a ride boy she
was like all in that whole getup and
even the the gondola itself and look
since I was pretty damn he went all out
yeah I think I'm trying to go about it
what about um New York yeah that's a
good on your is Times Square that's true
never been ten square either yes or no
to any Asian city there's so much more
lights that when you go to New York
Times Square you're like this is it
that's not as bad as that was the first
you gotta go first and then you go oh my
Times Square there's so much light and
then you go to Tokyo or Hong Kong or
whatever in your life watch Dolph Dolph
City Times Square yeah every
intersection in Asia is x squared yeah
Wow
when I went to uh we went two times for
the first time all time are you [ __ ]
sure
listen look way better
everywhere that's what I hear is like
you walk through Times Square all the
tours to go to Japan I think Shibuya it
makes plants grow things yeah really
yeah when you go to Shibuya crossing
your life Street anymore because it's
just like [ __ ] it's like yeah Japan
no I I when I first thought Times Square
I was like this is magnificent in it
because we were there to watch the ball
drop 13 hours later of being at X right
this is really tiny actually really look
at it like everything's really small
really miniature than when I first
experienced right but I still recommend
that people go because like I feel like
it's all about what you've experienced
before
so people like like you know that's
writing this [ __ ] they might they might
have traveled all over the world to like
trust me it's not worth it but like what
if you never left you know and that's
the first thing you see it's like why
you want to take away that happiness
from someone that's how I feel about the
major tourist attractions like just
around everywhere because she feels like
oh we all really have to go see you then
I'd rather see like the local stuff and
I'm like I'm down for that too but just
first let me guess you're just go
[ __ ] go like what's the big deal
Joe I just do it and then afterwards do
other stuff yeah I do get that it's like
going to LA in and you're like I want to
watch the Lakers let me show you these
underground basketball groups look like
well they're kind of known for the
Lakers so let me watch a Laker game
first and then we can go watch like the
little youth kids play at the market
yeah you guys want to hear another state
yeah Florida Florida Florida yeah you're
all Epcot please Epcot many I've caught
them in a Disney World the big round
diamonds intercept I thought I heard
yamas adult all right they have like a
world cool food haul it's this all
people from Florida we're saying that
Epcot and Animal Kingdom is the one to
go it's probably subjective I think it's
for sure who's riding this [ __ ] didn't
anyone ever tell some people to go to
Hollywood Walk of Fame you know
experience it I think the biggest
biggest tourist chops above all is
Moulin Rouge
have you guys [ __ ] on there know
whether it's a waste of [ __ ] time
is it crazy horrid everything so good
awesome
Mulan I wasn't even orny what it was
just like so like language is nothing
like the movie it's just a bunch it's
just a random variety show that has no
theme it's really good huh I felt like I
was watching a movie of titties and not
once was I around I was like a pong show
in Thailand you know Native women
short-circuited you because it yeah I
know yeah could I just talk [ __ ]
people flying out our [ __ ] and I'm like
no that's more of a circus show
when I was doing art circus
naked ballet or like when I saw the
Cabaret I was like oh wow so this is
like next-level sexuality but in a
different emotional experience versus
just raw [ __ ] like strip show like if
you go to strip club that's just raw
horny shake it shake that ass it's
purely like more primitive right and
this is like refined expression of sex I
was like an experience yeah I was like
oh this girl she [ __ ] wild and this one
she's playful and this one it's like
it's so dead what what is called two
crazy hands like so it's kind of like
that I don't know I've had an experience
Moulin Rouge but based off of what they
say Crazy Horse is like the higher end
of Mulan nice I need to see war which
sucks ass
but I think I still want to go because
there are people that enjoyed it yeah
even though he don't nice your money
she's like some I see how you feel
though like you wait like yeah he was
100% right but I need to experience it
for myself yes your parents are going to
do it yeah yeah I don't want to be like
well I didn't do it cuz he told me I
want to be like he told him how to do it
I still did it and I regretted it but
I'm glad how I felt after the ping pong
show you saw a ping pong show went with
my best friend I'm in in Thailand the
[ __ ] out of the King Kong I had so many
other things what she shot a dart out of
her vagina and hittable wool what she
got a coca-cola bottle that was coke and
then she poured it into her vagina and
then when she oh no it was
and then when she poured it back out it
was brown coca-cola and then she took a
sip from it look and then she pulled two
parakeets out of her know we're
imagining her vagina like a little Wow
all right sleeve drops up pulled needle
pull needles and like stuck them into
the they were like all attached to a
string and she like wow if a guy came
out with the franking erection her
vagina out arrayed bottles no no
literally just came out of the guy came
out and he played soccer with his
there's a girlfriend with a little
punkin poncho I had no I
I knew that it was like a ping pong show
that there were ping pong but it's like
the classic tile and thing like that
it's horrible but that's what it is and
so go and then we went and we were the
only two people in there I want to see
it everyone always talks about ever
giving me the show not died because that
would have all freaked out and I was
just like oh - ramat eyes petrified me
I've seen and this was in was an
Amsterdam it was a girl smoking a cigar
out of her vajayjay that - that's basic
she's a part of that I know and I just
ended with sex of guy with a black mask
came out with a black robe and he just
had sex with her on stage yeah and then
they bowed and that was yeah yeah that's
crazy any other stacy is on here
Wisconsin Oh what's up with confidence
it's not the cheese Mars cheese castle
yeah she told you horse trots what is
that they're known for their cheese
Harley yeah yeah what about Texas Texas
the Alamo oh really
I'm horrible don't you go to the hollow
ball I just saw from the outside reading
we didn't go in but its historical yeah
it was there any night time reading it
that's weird it was closing in the face
of it what about New Mexico New Mexico
area Roswell oh I play some ass Roswell
does suck
it's [ __ ] boring but I it sucks so
bad that I like it is worth it what is
that it's really bad it's just cheesy
I feel like the whole town is a tourist
trap yep like as soon as you get there
everything's alien branding yeah alien
store alien alien this alien whatever
and it's like I just wanted to go to see
how bad it was yeah didn't meet your
expectations of that I didn't get to go
in like because I didn't have time to
really stop there to sleep but it made
me want to go back next time but just
wander around I went to her in high
school
so when I was getting kicked out of
multiple schools during my high school
career
my mom's found like a military high
school in New Mexico I laugh and there's
a show that maybe you'll come here and
in the old shape up so we flew over
there and you have to drive three hours
from the airport
why Roswell and when we got there like
everything is alien theme like Joseph's
and this is back in the day like over
ten years ago when I was in high school
and when you go to Walmart Oh Blake the
sales all this world are you Syrian
alien like a spaceship really high aim
and news flash it's probably 20 years
now for you at high school that's not
more hundred-fifty
that's when it crashed the alien they
crashed near there like an actual alien
is that our area 51 is yes that's wrong
well I think so area 51 in Nevada yeah
so Roswell's different from area 51 yeah
there was an old yeah alien crap well I
went to a Chinese restaurant because
there's a Chinese restaurant everywhere
but to eat with my parents and we
ordered noodles and then it came out
hello Carly like the ramen noodles and
then when I went to go in the bath to
pee it was just stacks of the motto Chun
is the noodles and I'm like damn their
passion dishes Chinese food guys so
little Asians out there that it actually
works
Wow Wow yeah well if you guys want to
look at your own States or if you want
to check out what other tourists
Ruston's are in the US you can check out
a link in the description and see for
yourself hey guys would you think of
that video I know you loved it so make
sure to hit that like button to watch
more videos check it out up here
[Music]